こんにちは...
未だに
寒気がします。
はじめしゃちょーの部屋です
いえ、わたしははじめしゃちょーなんですけど
今日の動画ははじめしゃちょーに関する動画です。
あいかわらずこの部屋には何かがいるのではないか
そう疑って仕方がありません...
いやーやっぱ寒いんだよなーっというか怖いんだよなー。
普通にこの部屋にはねぇ霊の何かを感じるって言われたり
だから検証したりしたんですけどいまだにこうしっかりと何かをつかめたことはなく
なんかそれでもやっぱりこの辺には何故かものすごい・・・
何かがある( ﾟДﾟ)
それが何かがちょっと分からないんですけど
でも本当誰に言っても信じてくれないよぉーーー
みんな動画のネタだから何かしてるだけだろっていわれ..まあそうだけどね？
どぅがぁ（動画）のネタですが！
ほんとに何かしらを感じるんです。
そして、あの部屋おかしいってみんなから言われるんで
色々調べたんですけど
霊障っていうのがありましてぇ
それがその部屋にあるかどうかを確かめる方法があるみたいです。
用意するものは
こちら！
和紙。
和紙って何だろうって感じなんですけど何か要するに和風のなんか和製の紙だと思います。
わかんないけど。
あとお米ですね。うまそうだな。
この2つだけでこの部屋に霊がいるかいないか確かめていきたいと思います...
これ怖いんだよなこのネタ苦手なんだよなぁ...
じゃあやんなって話ですけど
そろそろちゃんと見つけたい、あの、皆さんにこう霊的なものを
やり方はいたって簡単で和紙の上にお米を乗せます
これなんか本に載ってたからガチっぽかったです。
はい乗りました
で元の米の色を覚えておきます。
まっ ちょっと写真だけ撮っておきます
これで後は簡単です
こういう感じですね お米を和紙に包みます
で これを使用者が就寝する前に
これを一緒に置いておきます
で、次の日の朝、お米の様子を開けて見ます
んでお米の色が茶色というかちょっと色が変色していたらその部屋は……
ちょっとやばいです。
そういう結果になってしまいます。
逆に何もなければ何もないの..かな...？..
これはですね本に載ってたやつなんで割とね信憑性があるというか割と信じてますね。
んでもう夜遅いのでこれと一緒に問題の部屋で寝ていこうと思います。
やっべぇマジでなんか今日マジでやばい気がすんだよね
何かもうちょっと復活で強いし
あぁ何かスッゲェいやな気がすんだよなー
えっともっかい確かめてみましょう
「白い和紙でお米を包み、就寝時 枕元
(枕の近く) 枕の近くに置いておきましょう。」
一晩でもう変色するらしいです。
一応この子も枕元に置いておきます。
いや こいつはマジで救いの手だから、じゃあ枕元に失礼します.............
おやすみなさい
じゃあもう寝るね、おやすみ
(聞こえただろうか...彼の頭の上に怪しい物音が聞こえた)
(彼のいびきに共鳴するように何かが動いている)
(チッと聞こえた)
(うるさいいびきに耐え切れず)
(幽霊が舌打ちしたように聞こえるのだ)
(さらにこの後信じられない音が聞こえるのだ)
(和太鼓のような音が聞こえた)
(…太鼓の達人だろうか？)
(完全に太鼓の達人である)
(その後もこの部屋では変な音が絶えずに聞こえ続けたのであった)
(そして...)
(大丈夫じゃないようだ)
ｳﾙｻｲﾖ!! (ﾟДﾟ#)
(確かにうるさい)
(彼は初音ミクちゃんの目覚ましに起こされ)
(朝を迎えたのです)
あ
おはようございます
何かねいつもよりね気が進まないというわけで
一晩経って、これの中の色がどうなってるでしょうか、見てみます
やばい……
わからん！！
((((( ドーーーン )))))
だってこれ分かんなくね？？
一応写真を撮ったんですけど比較してみましょうはい
イマイチ分かりません
ちょっとカメラの設定と部屋の光も 一緒にしたんですけど
何でだ
何だろうよく分かんねー
何かもっと分かりやすい何かあればいいですけどね
この部屋には霊がいますみたいなそういうのがあったら
よかったらコメント欄で書いてください
三度寝してきまーす